how characters should have looked
according to comics comic book movie
costumes are getting more and more
accurate with every film that's released
the outfit featured in Deadpool set the
new standard and both Black Panther and
spider-man's costumes in Captain America
Civil War look fantastic but for every
comic accurate costume there are plenty
more page to screen adaptations that are
just wrong sometimes ignoring original
designs is a smart decision while other
times it's hard not to be bummed about
the changes made for the sake of realism
here are some of the most off-kilter
attempts to put super suits on the big
screen from the past present and future
Wolverine back when Hugh Jackman first
took the role of Wolverine in 2000's
x-men it was impressive enough that he
accurately captured the essence of
everyone's favorite clawed psychopath
it didn't matter much that at 6 to
Jackman stands a full 11 inches taller
than his super short comic book
counterpart but despite the fact that
fans have loved the movie version of
Wolverine for over a decade he still
never appeared on-screen in his comic
accurate costume come on can't we even
get the mask on his face just once vibe
we can't really blame the producers of
The CW's the flash for not going so
comic book accurate with this one for
one thing Cisco Ramon aka vibe is still
discovering his powers on the show and
hasn't gone out to fight crime as a
full-on superhero moreover until a
recent redesign vibes comic books suit
was pretty embarrassing with its red
handkerchief and v-neck collar that goes
all the way down still if the show keeps
looking to score points for comic book
accuracy we have to point out that it's
missed this one even when it makes the
smart choice by actually avoiding it
Hawkeye this is another instance where
the filmmakers behind Hawkeye's
big-screen look made the right move by
moving away from the comics sure
Hawkeye's all purple archery suit looks
cool on the page but it'd be hard not to
make it look ridiculous at the movie
theater Superman lots of Superman haters
have pointed to his costume as something
in need
fixing with the yellow belt that holds
nothing up the red underpants on the
outside and the basic blue spandex it's
definitely a simple outfit and one that
hasn't changed much over the past
century but Christopher Reeve managed to
make it look awesome in 1978 Superman
and all three of the sequels that was
proof enough that Superman's costume
wasn't actually broken at all yet for
some reason Zack Snyder insisted on
making Superman's belt even weirder and
cover him in fish scales for 2013's Man
of Steel bring the underpants back man
Deadpool much has already been said
about how badly the film's producers
screwed up the character they take him
out of his iconic costume sew his mouth
shut and give him all of the mutant
powers they could stuff into one person
the good news of course is that it paved
the way for 2016 s Deadpool which has
broken new ground for faithful
comic-book adaptations and for creative
use of a unicorn doll in an r-rated
movie
Punisher while it's not going to win any
awards for being clever the Punishers
costume is pretty memorable for exactly
one reason it has a gigantic white skull
on it so when the Dolph Lundgren
starring Punisher movie came out in 1989
what's the one thing the filmmakers
decided to omit from the characters look
the gigantic white skull fortunately all
the on-screen Punishers since then have
let good sense prevailed and stuck huge
white skull shaped targets on their
chests phew mystique as we've discussed
the producers of 2000's x-men made some
important choices to ensure that their
team of mutants would look realistic on
film that meant cutting brightly colored
superhero costumes in favor of black
leather whether or not that was a more
believable costume choice is debatable
but there's no question that director
Bryan Singer's move to change the look
of mystique is one of the more baffling
adaptations in superhero movie history
for some reason singer insisted that the
villain be covered in lizard scales and
walk around naked all day long despite
there being no such corresponding look
in the comics stranger still the scales
have stuck around from movie to movie
and actors to actress even
how it looks truly bizarre and has no
real reason to still be like a thing
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to see more videos like
the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which comic book
costume you want to see on film